we don't have a lot of democracy in
America today and we have the formal
sort of institutions we have
representative government and and we
have a bill of rights but the fact is
that the representative government
doesn't work very well via the electoral
system is dominated by wealth and so I
mean for instance an upcoming
presidential election the people most
people I speak to cannot find a
candidate that they like they have no
choice the candidates have been selected
for them and they have Republican or
Democrat and third party candidates
don't have a chance the political system
therefore is is very limited and even
freedom of speech and press which are
supposedly guaranteed in the bill of
rights they have very severely
constricted by the control of the press
now the control of all of the arenas of
free speech by huge corporations that
control the major television channels
and control of major newspapers so the
sure we are more democratic than an
absolutist and totalitarian state but we
in the United States are still quite a
long way from democracy and certainly a
long way from economic democracy because
of the control of the economy by
corporations and the tax structure which
is set up by an unrepresentative
Congress and approved by a president a
tax structure which has so far channeled
the wealth of the country towards the
richest 1% of the population